oh I found a cheerleader stop school she
was always right there when I need her
we're going to pause all we take care of
this mini situation hello believe nation
my niece is Megan and Samantha are here
from California they love doing
gymnastics and they're going to teach me
a few things and I'm going to see if I
can do it too let's see what happens
one foot the other things
okay so you can start like this come on
that's quality that's quality I'll be
like up taking watch me do it for like
this that'd be all on camera time
first of all that's an amazing ride when
it that was amazing oh well we can if I
can't do it i'm blaming my coach don't
blame you coat one foot then the other
friends
you
change of plans here will not be give me
a back bend or a bridge this is my
sister Alexandra you know he's not ready
for back
Wow okay thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed let us know
what you think in the comments below and
don't forget to you could style hello
believe nation my cousins Megan because
there's nothing because hello believe
nation my OC cuzs again feel like I'm
working with amateurs okay hello believe
nation my cousins are anything this is
my sister Stephanie from Africa yeah the
silly one and everybody chicken tickle
tickle Samantha one whoa